foreign
what's up Lindsay
hello what's up you are you're oh
yeah hi oh my God it's awesome that I'm
talking to you guys I know you too
what's happening
okay so this is not a happy topic but
I'm happy right now okay all right
excellent excellent what's up sorry I'm
just excited
um I we are getting sued all right me
and my husband we are getting sued by
the credit card company okay I can feel
you smiling as you're saying the words
so we're getting sued
yes we are getting sued not a great time
but you know God says joy and you know
the hardness I don't know how but we are
but anyways I am a mess I don't know
where to go from here uh We've made this
hole for ourselves pretty deep I know
Dave Ramsey I've done the book I've done
financial pieces my husband he's not
always on board he did not read the book
but I read the book all right
I am struggling we don't have we're not
on baby step one at all we're not on any
baby steps we're getting sued I talked
to a lawyer he or paying a lawyer I'm
just I'm frazzled I don't know where to
go from here biblically spiritually they
Ramsey Lee okay I want to stop you there
first thing is
I want you to take as deep a breath as
humanly possible as deep as you can I
want you to hold it okay
hold it
for one
two three exhale let it out
now I want you to take your elbows
and I want you to pull them towards the
floor so your shoulders are super far
away from your ears
okay okay pull them all the way down
here's my promise
the sun's gonna come up and y'all are
going to be on the other side of this
okay
okay it'll be a mess to get through it
that's all good I've been through messes
Jade's been through messes we all go
through messes you will come out on on
the other side of this cool
yeah that's my problem okay so how big
Oh and before we get into the into the
details
no more talking bad about my friend
Lindsay Fair
have you done stupid stuff
all the time okay that's it me too
me too
the only thing we can do is work on
moving forward but if you carry that
around you know the difference between
guilt and shame the the difference
between guilt and shame is this
guilt you do something dumb you you
borrowed a bunch of money you didn't
have and then all of a sudden the debts
come due and you don't have the money to
pay it and somebody sues you and you're
holding this cinder block
and you're holding it that's guilt that
was dumb your body's telling you it's
dumb your friends tell you it's dumb the
banker tells you it's done it was dumb
shame is when you put that sucker in
your backpack and you say I'm dumb
and you're not
okay I want you to say stop yeah I'm
positive I'm positive okay I wouldn't be
doing this if I thought everyone who
made mistakes were mistakes themselves
okay okay I would I would be doing
something else with my life
that's my promise okay so we can dig
into the numbers but I want you to make
sure you're with me full on that this is
not an unsalvageable mess okay and
notice I don't even know what the
numbers are
but I'm sitting next to a woman who paid
off almost half a million dollars of a
hole me and my wife paid off
um six figures
of a humongous hole
so I know us too and it well Jayden and
Sam are brilliant smart me and my wife
aren't stop that okay
so we can do oh actually my wife's
pretty smart I was gonna say don't push
ES
but all it says you're good okay we
Square it up now let's get into the
numbers part of it so how much are we
looking at for the credit card debt that
you're being sued for
so
um there might be three lawsuits but
right now there's two okay um for sure
two is twelve thousand like 700 and some
change okay and the second one is four
thousand and like 300 and some change
and they're both in different courts
because of the amount but okay so I I we
were able to settle it in the very
beginning when we weren't able to pay
and we had the money kind of sorted we
could have borrowed some of us from a
family member but
um honestly I think Pride got in the way
and we were just like why are why are we
paying them we've been paying them for
years and it hasn't gone down very much
and you get in that hole of like credit
cards you're evil but it's not like we
didn't no right it's not like you just
know that they charged with interest so
sure I don't know but sometimes people
don't understand exactly how it's
accumulating
right yeah um
yeah and so we just we actually had 16
different types of debts
um since 2015 and I and my husband have
paid them off one by one great snowball
that's great
how much have you paid off Lindsay
um like maybe around in total probably
around 60 000. come on very good
incredible you're at the Finish Line you
got three left
hey well we made mistakes with the three
left the three left is like who cares
I think you're focusing more on the what
you're perceiving as a loss than you are
on all the wins that you've had along
the way
and by the way let's cut to it are you
getting sued as an attorney contacted
you or did you get one of those letters
from somebody saying they're
representing such and such credit card
um uh I'm pretty sure well I got it from
the county the county person came to my
door okay
I was like you're like a real one yeah
these are the last three you've got left
they're suing you okay you've paid off
sixty thousand dollars this is great
what how much money are you working with
every month that you're putting into
your snowball
um well that's where you that's why I
called because uh there's nothing we've
been we've been Reckless we've been
acting like we've been debt free kind of
all right let's do this this is an
important call Lindsay and there's
millions of Americans going through this
I'm going to hold you over to the break
before the break you said you and your
husband have just kind of been messing
around just kind of making dumb
decisions tell me more about that
ah do I have I'm just kidding
um mostly honestly when I do my
budgeting we don't stick to our budget
that's our biggest thing is we don't
stick to the budget and then fun things
happen or people invite us places and we
say sure but then I look at the budget
and I'm like we really shouldn't do that
but then we don't stick to the budget
and we're like that's fine I have a
question
I have a question and I might be being a
little hard on you
um no well go ahead I'm used to it I
just I'm like what is more is it gonna
take you're getting sued like what what
type of situation you are I mean clearly
you already had lots of debt so you felt
the weight of that you felt some of the
freedom from getting out beneath under
uh from beneath that debt
um the minute you kind of let your foot
off the gas you're over here you I think
you said you had three uh debts left and
you're getting sued why I I I'm
struggling to understand how that's not
enough to make you go wake up call like
we need to just finish this out and we
need to I'm trying to understand why
there wasn't a behavior shift there
I think honestly to be honest I don't
like to shift blame anywhere right just
to myself because I can only control
myself sure but in my marriage
um one person
didn't agree with Dave Ramsey one person
who shall rename remain nameless
nameless right and unidentified right
um he didn't agree with the whole Dave
Ramsey mindset he didn't agree with the
you need a credit score you need a
credit card did you need this and I'm
like uh no I was just like no you you
don't you don't need any of that you
just need cash cash is like literally
king that's all you need so you're
attributing this to you and your husband
not being on the same page basically
yes I think that was the biggest thing
that was the hardest was we weren't on
the same page because he just didn't see
it he didn't read it he didn't
experience it like I he went to
Financial Peace University and he was
with the idea but when it came to
actually doing it he wasn't with it you
know so John is going to talk to you
about that
um let me give you just a quick take
away from this being sued situation
um you're gonna get sued and you may
have to go to court if you can't get
them to settle with you ahead of time my
guess is because I know you've paid off
sixty thousand dollars of debt you
probably have the money to clear the 4
000 one of the debts is 4 300 you can
probably pay that this month
it's that money is laying around
somewhere I know it is it's in your
budget you guys you you guys need to
look at the budget and get that thing
settled call them up say hey we'll give
you 2 000 we have it in cash settle it
same thing with the one that's for 12
700 settle it for pennies on the dollar
dimes on the dollar and get free of that
what how much is the third debt
um the third tip I don't remember I
think it's around the five or six
thousand dollar Mark they haven't sent
us really any letters they defaulted it
I'm pretty sure okay so it's just in
default election agency so we're let's
there's three debts left it's the debt
snowball smallest to largest so we're
gonna do the four thousand three hundred
dollar one because the other one is in
judgment we're gonna go ahead and do
that one and then clear out the five
thousand dollar one okay you guys have
the money in the margin to do this
but
and John's going to talk to you about
this it's not it's not a magic trick
right you guys understand you have to
put in the work so if they make a
judgment against you it's literally just
going to be a yet another set of people
telling you you have to pay this right
so we don't want it to get that far it's
already you know your credit's destroyed
and that doesn't matter anyway but you
got to pay it yeah so John yeah I I have
I would kick myself if I didn't ask this
and then maybe wait out of line here
um
are you safe
oh yeah you're good yes like you mean
like safe as an emotional like am I
being kept am I in a house like is that
what you're saying I just want to make
sure you're all right
oh no I'm no I'm I'm perfectly fine okay
so I'm more than safe here's here's the
path forward I don't want y'all to
mention Dave Ramsey anymore because Dave
Ramsey's become
um it's become a third rail excuse
and it's easy for your husband to
dismiss some old guy
who's got glasses who lives in Nashville
it's easy just to dismiss that guy and
it's easy for you to not be honest about
what you need and what you want and the
dreams you have and just pin them all on
this old guy in Nashville Tennessee
and so I want you to stop using Dave
Ramsey as an excuse as a marker as a way
to coerce or manipulate or push your
husband into getting you what you want I
want you to do the hard scary terrifying
thing and be courageous and sit down and
tell your husband I'm so scared I can't
breathe
so scared that I can't live like this
knowing that at any moment
if you say the wrong dumb thing at work
you're fired and we are out of our house
that if I say the wrong thing at work
and I get fired in this current world we
live in we lose both cars because we
have nothing or we're about to get a
judgment against us
for X number of dollars plus lawyer fees
plus whatever emotional damage the
credit card company thinks they've
endured
and what's it going to take husband
because right now you're acting a lot
more like his mom than you are his wife
or even it can I more maybe even a kid
because do you want to know what my son
does my son will say Mom ZZ wants to
watch a movie ZZ wants to know if she
can have ice cream and that's my
daughter and so he pins it on her
thinking he has a bet she has a he has a
better chance of getting it he's being
just a good kind brother asking for a
sister but what he really wants is he he
wants to watch TV or a movie he wants
ice cream and I so agree with what John
is saying when you pin everything on
Dave Ramsey wants us to
get on a budget that's right Dave Ramsey
you know and not feeling comfortable
enough within your marriage to say I
want here's what I want to do and here's
what I believe is going to help
you know this is just yeah this is you
know and just being free and open to
share yeah
yeah and sometimes
um people
nag and complain and whine to their
spouse about getting with the plan and
they don't get it with the plan because
either one of two things
the person's not on the like you're not
fully on either you say yes to stuff too
or you've got had a bunch of schemes
over the course of your relationship
with this guy and he's like oh I'm gonna
do this let's do this have you tried
this let's try this and Dave Ramsey is
just yet another scheme and a long line
of of skiing that may not be you guys
you guys have clearly gone after it and
done it and done it and done it and done
it but at some point you have to have
the courage to look at him and say
I'm tired of being scared in my own home
I'm tired of feeling unsafe will you be
a part of building a new marriage where
we are completely unified in this deal
and we are safe together and then you
can have the peripheral discussion after
that which is well I feel safe with a
credit card well I don't feel safe with
a credit card would you feel safe with
six months and cash in the bank so we're
Our Own Credit Card yes I can buy that
cool that's in the plan
but you see how those steps become a
part of how do you fulfill this new
identity it doesn't become the reason
why you do everything we gotta do the
baby steps no man you got to get out of
debt and keep your family safe yeah heal
your marriage the steps just help you
get there you see the difference
yes okay I want you to hang on the line
I'm going to send you a couple of things
I'm gonna send you
um Financial Peace University the
updated one and it's going to be on me
and missing you every dollar the best
budgeting app in the world for a year
the premium one that links to your bank
and I'm gonna send you a copy of own
your pass change your future my book on
figuring out what do I do next okay I
want you all to read that stuff go
through it and change everything